um we have an awesome talk lining up
Richie think um the author of Polar it's
already mentioned in a couple of talks
um repop uh Library uh recently also
founded a company around it give a big
Applause to Richie
[Applause]
think hi thank you can you all hear me
yeah cool um yeah thanks for the
introduction I'll repeat parts of it my
name is Rich you think I'm the author of
polars um I have a background in machine
learning and software development mostly
um and since a short time I'm also a
co-founder of a company um we're also
hiring so if you have a strong
background in Rust and are interested in
databases reach out that would be
awesome um today I'm going to talk a bit
about what polers is so very short
introduction can I get a raise of hands
of people who use it
already ah gets better better and people
who know it heard of it oh great um
going to talk about Expressions going to
talk a bit about
optimizations um in with scope of
Expressions not about all of them going
to talk a bit about parallelism and then
I want to introduce poers plugins which
is something really new really fresh um
we're still working on it uh not
yesterday but the day before in the
evening um so what polers is poers is a
query engine which focuses on a data
frame front end and as a query engine it
respects Decades
of uh of research in relational
databases um we use laser evaluation
which means we get query optimizations
uh which can give uh a lot of
performance benefits uh um we minimize
materializations um by introducing Ching
copy of copy of right or making
operation slice aware if you for
instance do a sord but you only need the
first 100 rows you don't have to
materialize all the data in the sort
operation um the data types are
constructed to amortize access and
allocation costs um it's written in a
lowle language it's written in Rust
which gives us full exess of memory and
full control over performance where we
need it and also gives us very much
control of how we use parallelism how us
treading um and it's therefore really
designed for Effective parallelism from
the ground up um we're also designed for
outof core processing which is a fancy
word for processing data sets that don't
fit into memory um and we have very
tight integration with IO which means
that when we read something from dis we
read it immediately in the proper memory
format so we don't have double
copies um that's very short
introduction um and I want to talk about
polar Expressions polar expression s are
first class citizens in polus they're
super important and they're used
everywhere and as a type there sort of a
function which Tak in they're a pure
functional function um pure in the sense
that they don't have side effects and
they take state of a data frame the
state of the inputs so multiple series
and possibly the state of groups and it
produces a new series and series are
composable which means you can combine
them
indefinitely and with this composability
you get get a lot
of um complexity you can solve you can
do a lot of stuff by
composing um Expressions it's very
similar to how for instance a language
like python the actual Grammer or the
actual vocabulary is pretty small but
you can combine all those keywords like
for Loops like uh all the functions to
to do to do anything basically um and
expressions they they the inputs can
mean different things it can mean a
column but they can also mean a group
they can mean elements in a list they
can mean a single value they can be
literals um yeah so so so they are the
core part of the polus
API um and we are very serious about it
um that means that if you use uh a map
elements which is similar to an apply in
pandas where you use a python function
to load something and you get python
objects back we don't want you to do
that you should use an expression for
that and why do we do that that's
because um using python functions you
get python objects um you must hold the
gild the global interpreter lock which
skills
parallelization um and we don't know
what you're doing so there's a lot of
stuff we cannot do we cannot do
optimizations and we cannot do
parallelism and it will also be slower
so we cannot use our own very optimized
code um and the these optimizations are
important um because they take
responsibility from a programmer and we
are super familiar with libraries like
numai um numai is the best best example
here um with numai we know that if we
knew if we use numai correctly we get
one promise of a c compiler and that is
that we get factorization right you get
C Level performance but there's one
thing we don't get and that is
optimizations um if you would compile
your program in C you would get the
second part as well the compiler would
recognize that some stuff you do is
redundant or can be done faster or can
can be combined in a single register um
we can also not give you those
optimizations on register level but we
can give you those optimizations on
columnar level we can prove that some
operations are not needed that we can do
some operations in a single uh
allocation for instance so we want to
give you both things we want to give you
C- level performance and we want to give
you
optimizations um and these optimizations
can give you very significant benefits
here we have a a quy what the query does
isn't that important it's just that the
first time we run this query without
optimizations the second one the second
time we run the same query with
optimizations there's no caching in
between and we get a 4. 5x speed up
without doing anything this is just um
the optimizer that that does this for
you um and the benefit is that you can
write your code semantically you should
not worry with which columns do I need
to load where should I apply the filter
where should no the responsibility of
the user is making sure the query is
correct and readable and semantically
does the right
thing um here's an example of an
optimization we do there there are many
optimizations I will not go through all
of them um but this is an example where
we use common sub expression
elimination um as you can see we compute
the mean we compute the sum um but the
input of the mean function and the input
of the sum function is equal right um we
both we twice multiply the two columns
so um you could apply an optimization
where you say Okay I I assign a
temporary column where I do this mul
multiplication and then I compute the
mean and I compute the sum this is
something that the optimizer does for
you um there are very there are a lot of
optimizations uh the optimizer does for
you um I will go through a few of them
um one important one is that we check
the schemas that means that before we
run the query we check if the D types
are correct
and this is very important as this saves
you a lot of time if you would run the
query immediately and maybe your query
fails 20 minutes in you will get very
late feedback would be very annoying if
you to discover that if you have a fault
in your
querry that it that it fails mid time
you want to have failures as soon as
possible um this gives a way better use
experience and you
also um
yeah um are more you trust better that
your that your querry is correct we do
projection push down which means we take
the columns you want to read we read
them at the scan level at the moment we
read the files read The Columns from the
files we don't read columns we don't
need if you would do this naively you
would first read a whole pet file and
then select the columns which would be
wasteful right because I loaded I loaded
bytes from dis into memory and then I
dropped them um we do the same for for
predicates for filters so if you skip
rows we do this at the scan level to
ensure that those rows are not
materialized we do we do the checks in
pet files there are also statistics and
it can be possible sometimes to prove
that we don't need to read whole row
groups and we can skip whole bunches of
data at a time
we um change the ordering of of branches
in a in a join sometimes it's faster to
First evaluate the left part of a join
uh because we know the table is smaller
for instance so we we keep some
cardinality um we do scan sharing so if
you have
a um if you read a file multiple times
and you join that on the same query for
instance we recognize this hey this this
part of the query is used multiple times
we can we could execute it twice or we
could store it in a cache and just keep
it in the cach as long as you need it
um um this is very similar to Common s
expression elimination and common s plan
elimination which eliminate um
duplicates in your carry or things we
can cache We cach Them
temporarily um the second thing you get
with po expression is parallelism and
you get them for free without thinking
of parallelism you can only think of
semantically of your code and we use a
strategy for this and this is called
work stealing and work stealing
um means that we push tasks tasks to be
executed on a on a tread pool um and we
have a queue of tasks and if you look at
those um if you look at those those
scores so here we we visualize three
cores and every core has got a queue of
tasks and we can publish task on a cure
on a queue and then that queue will
process uh process the task has to
finish and one it one once it is done
done with its queue so in the second
image we see that the third core is done
with its work the queue is empty it can
fetch some work from another core that's
called work stealing so it steals some
work another core is doing um and as you
see the second queue has aled because
it's now done by two two threads or two
cores
um this
means this really helps um to saturate
your cores so we have a tread pool which
is commonly set to the amount of cores
you have and those cores are always busy
with useful work um publishing task to a
to to a queue is very cheap it doesn't
require any
sterilization it doesn't have any thread
startup cost so starting a tread from
the OS is pretty expensive but we always
have the threads in the tread pool
locally so we never have to start them
the Treads are already already
ready stealing work requires temporary
temporary lock
so therefore we try to make the tasks
big
enough
um so you don't want to have a lot of
super small task but you want to
distribute the task the task should
should be reasonably big but this is not
something the user has to be worrying
about this is something we optimize for
you and we try to create tasks that that
yeah that are well divided over the
course um and because the amount amount
of threads we spin up in our thread pool
is equal or smaller than the amount of
threads amount of cores on your machine
the doesn't need a swap between threads
a thread can just finish its work if you
would say you would start thousand cores
thousand threads on a on a on a dual
core
machine then the OS would need to swap
between every threads to to give that
thread some on time and this swapping is
very really expensive so you don't want
to have this you want to minimize this
um
and here's an example of how we would
split some tasks in polars um let's say
we have a data frame where we create
some groups and some data and um in the
first one we take column B and we want
to compute the number of unique elements
there
um here we recognize that Computing the
number of unique elements is pretty
expensive um it's not a cheap operation
you need to do some hashing you need to
create a hash table put put elements in
there so we will create a parallel task
for this we also recognize that this is
the only expression that runs so we have
course left to run so we create some
tasks for it and run it on tread que and
once nunique is finished with Computing
we do multiply times two but we know
that arithmetic is pretty cheap and we
have simd factorization so we don't want
to create any parallelism for that the
parallelism probably is more expensive
than doing the operation so we don't
parales that one if we run the same
expression so the power of Pol
expression is that you can run them in
in many context or you can run an
expression in a select but you can also
run it in a group bu and it has the same
semantic meaning um but in a group buy
you can we paralyze over the group so
let's say you have a million groups and
we paralyze over it if we would also
paralyze the an unique task you would
get a lot of smaller tasks um because
per group per million groups you would
also create let's say 100 tasks if you
would do that that would explode the
number of tasks you have so here we here
we only paraly over the group and again
for the multiply times two we use a
single task because we can prove that we
don't need a group to do to to do
arithmetic right um the times two
doesn't matter what the groups
are this is all done for you you don't
have to think about it you just write
querry um the tread pool in poers is not
bound to a single querry that means you
can use poers as a work
scheduler uh in something like airflow
and just push right your querry and push
it on a on a async cure or a uh and
collect everything and it will
distribute um the work on the single
machine it will ensure the work is
divided over the course you can accept
the work on the server
um collect it and and and um return it
but you will not saturate the
servers um course because you will use
the polar thread pool um and you get can
get YOLO po you can get polers you can
use polers as a compute library and get
very effective parallelism I want to go
a bit more about this later in this
talk um
so yeah an important thing as a result
of the design of polars um
being focused on parallelism being
focused on writing everything designing
everything from the ground up um using
optimiz using um optimizations that
are already done in in most qu engines
we see the polers as very good
performance it has um yeah I think it's
among the fastest open source query
engines uh out there within an order of
magnitude of those uh those results this
is a tpch benchmark the TPC Benchmark is
a benchmark typically run in uh database
in the database world it's got also more
typically database like problems um for
data
frames um you could probably better have
a different Benchmark with more data
frame as operations um yeah this is a
good
um Benchmark to see where it stands on
on complete queries um you can see more
about these benchmarks on a website you
can also see more benchmarks on the
docdb website where they done the
database Benchmark website uh Benchmark
which is more on operations and not on
uh
optimizers
um and I want to show a bit more about
pois plugins so pois plugins is
um is something new so you can also
benefit from this expression engine and
the idea is that you can compile your
own um your own plugins you can compile
your own binaries and hook them into the
Polar Engine and then you can run your
Expressions without interference of
python so you can register as a them as
a dynamic Library into the polar's
engine and then you can call them from
python but they will run without
interference of Python and the benefit
of this is that we don't have any guil
contention so for instance if you do
this expression in this group buy where
you have thousands of groups we would
call this expression thousands of times
um if you would have the Gill
there uh thousands of times in parallel
if you would have the gild there that
would be a yeah a central point of
locking so it would slow things down um
and with this you won't have that so let
me show a little bit about how this
works
so here's an example
of um an example create where we've
shown it you can create a new crate
which is are people here familiar with
rust I'm going to show a little bit of
rust code but not too
much
slsh okay they use snake case so that's
familiar um maybe that's what it um you
can start a new crate and you can say
okay I have some source and
for instance let's say I want to make an
extension in polers where I create
different distance functions um I can
create
several um functions which compute a
distance so we have a he heign distance
we have
a a hemming distance you can have a few
more right this is just Ros code which
computes the distance you uh you have to
uh trust me on this that this does what
it does here here's the interesting part
you can create a a an expression or a
function that takes in as input a polar
series oh sorry for this that takes in
as input the polar series and returns a
result with a polar series and here here
you've got this implementation of this
function which is up to you to to create
that and then you annotate it with this
attribute and this attribute will do all
the magic for you this attribute will
expose this s a c function um we'll
ensure that uh it creates a few more
functions which we can hook up then and
then we're out of the rust world and we
can go back to the python world then in
the python world we
can um we can create a new clause
and um we can from polls. .ut udfs we
can create we can import the function
get shared lip location the only thing
that this does is uh find the shared lip
for you which we
compiled and then you can create a
distance Nam space so we use an
attribute here or a decorator which
gives us the information of how this
namespace is going to be called so we're
going to call it disc and then we
register the
plugins um so here we have the hemming
distance we have the jard similarity and
the have sign and here in the keyword
arguments we can add some extra
functionality which describ cribe to the
optimizer how this function behaves if
this function is element wise we can
apply certain optimizations if it's not
element wise for instance a sort is not
element wise a sort needs all data we
cannot do some optimizations um we
cannot um we cannot naively dispatch
that to every thread for instance
because a sword needs to communicate um
in any case you can then compile this
function and then once it's compiled it
creates this shared Library here here we
see it and then we can just from polars
or from another python file we can
import polers which is the the PO from
pipie which we just downloaded and then
from our own expression lip we can
import our new namespaces for instance
we import distance and that's all we
need to do and then we can just here we
create a new disc or we use this
expression we say column. names. disc.
Hamming distance and we give the inputs
now if we run this this will run it will
produce the outputs and it will run
without interference of python so we
only use Python to register the dynamic
Library we say here is the dynamic
dynamic Library here's how to reach it
and later we can say we want to use this
function then polers builds a logical
plan and will'll run this query
completely in Rust and you can now
create your own namespaces or your own
extensions and this will be very
interesting if you want to do stuff
which is more exotic which doesn't fit
into the Polish Library per se if you
want to do uh for instance NLP
processing which is pretty specific
domain specific or you want to do
genomics you can now create your own
your own Expressions you can focus on
the implementation of that make sure
that's correct you can register in it on
the Polar Engine but you will get
parallelism you will get
optimizations you will get all the
benefits Expressions have you can use
them in a pivot in a groupby in a select
you can use them anywhere but you can
extend with your own domain specific uh
logic um that's what I wanted to show
you this is very
new
[Music]
um and I've got a last
word and that is
that um yeah go to the project uh follow
us on GitHub join our Discord as well uh
there's a lot if you want to learn more
about Pol there's a lot very active
Discord there are a lot of people um
they are really helpful um understanding
how how Stuff work and there's a
new a new
um I've got something new there's a
python polish coming in a Riley book uh
it's going to be written by T who sits
here on the front they just got the
early release they almost finished the
early release and they can share it in
the Discord so if you join the Discord
um in a few weeks I think the the PDF
will be shared and you can already take
a look and they want some feedback on
that um so the book is going to be out
next year um yeah this is exciting news
um I never thought there would be a book
about something I I've written so uh
yeah that's really cool thank you and uh
if there are questions please
ask thank you for the talk